foreign
Chris is in Canada hi Chris welcome to
the Ramsey Show
better than we deserve how can we help
um I just had a question in the long
term long time listener
I never really had a reason to call
other than the other day Okay your
phone's cutting out man speak directly
into your phone
okay how's that much better thank you
kicked out
um and they're asking they're not asking
us to help but I mean they've asked us a
whole bunch of times uh to help with
bills and to pay things and they're just
they're not great with their money and
they don't make a whole lot of it they
don't work a lot so we just don't really
know what to do to help them
how old are you
okay
30.
30 yeah yeah and how long you been
married
two years been together 10 years yeah so
these people are in their 50s
every round yeah mid 50s almost late
yeah
okay do you even have the ability to
help
is this a frustration question or is
this a
math problem question
uh we're going through the baby steps
ourselves we're paying off our own debt
so I mean we don't have the financial
ability to help all that much but
um we do have a house of our own that we
can bring them into but I mean it'll be
really tight if the two of them it's her
younger sister if she's got two kids I
got two dogs
so it would be really tight and I mean
we wouldn't really want the ramp her
alone so younger sister has two kids and
she lives with them also
yeah she's about like 20 24 25. she
working today you know
so this isn't a matter of helping out
this is a matter of transferring
complete dysfunction this is a mess
um it is a mess yeah I mean they
yeah they don't the the one the father
Works mainly and then he works with a
construction company and he's good at
his job when he when he has work but I
mean he's working very little
yeah he doesn't work much the daughter
doesn't work at all and Mama doesn't
work at all there's kids and dogs all
over the place and they don't pay their
bills
uh yeah it's hard for them no it's hard
for them because they don't work
yeah I mean I don't I don't know where
my wife got to work ethic from but she
worked two jobs
I don't either because these people
don't work
sometimes people grow up in a situation
and they say not never again and maybe
that's your wife
yeah yeah because she kind of grew up in
it a little bit so Tim one of the most
painful things that we do as an adult
is we watch people that we love
friends or family
do stupid things
and misbehave
and there's nothing we can do about it
and we hurt for them more than they hurt
for themselves
it's very hard
yeah when uh when we were speaking to
her mother she kind of seeing a little
bit cool common collected and working
over here like are you how are you
relaxed right now like you can't pay
your bills you're kind of struggling
you're thinking being kicked out like I
think that's an important thing for you
to notice about yourself you can't care
more about them than they do about
themselves
yeah yeah I get that they're not
children
yeah I'm sorry I hate it it's not harsh
but here's the thing if you gave them
ten thousand dollars
and they got completely current
in one year they're going to be right
back here again aren't they
that the conversation I've had
we said we could win the lottery
tomorrow and we can give them a house
and five hundred thousand dollars for
any money but I mean they've come back
eventually yeah
yeah and so there's no amount there's no
amount of funding
help that's going to actually help
until they change
would you agree with that
uh I agree so throwing money at them is
uh almost hurtful because it's kind of
like you're giving a drunk a drink
we call that enabling we call that
enabling
do for them but kind of kind of convince
them in a way to kind of
I don't know go and get a job or going
to work you know I really wouldn't say
anything to them about them I would just
talk about what you guys are doing and
say you know we we figured out if we
work a lot that we have more money
we figured out that if we live on a
budget and control our spending very
carefully that we don't have as much
stress because we're never behind and I
would make statements about yourself and
then if they ever go wow I'd be cool to
do that I said I would be honored to
show you how to do that I'd be honored
to work with you and Coach you on how to
do that I'll be your biggest cheerleader
but I'm not ever giving you another dime
again
because money doesn't help them Tim
they need a new set of information
plugged into their computer
yeah
they have you know their program is
corrupted
I remember when I was in college I had
an opportunity to leave school and go do
something and the guy was we're back and
forth and I was like dude I'm not
dropping out of college it's stupid it
was a cool opportunity but I'm not going
to leave school and he told me something
that has stuck with me forever even
though I ended up finishing school and
all that
he said the people who are successful
don't have a backup plan and I said why
negos because they'll use it
and that was silly Instagram advice
before there was Instagram but there's
something to
until your father-in-law realizes
there's no there's no there's no
superhero coming this time
I'm just gonna have to stay at work and
make more money until your sister
realizes that there isn't just some
money doesn't fall out of the clouds to
help her two little babies who are
desperate need of somebody giving them
some structure and some support
um
until there's continues to be a backup
plan they're going to continue to use I
mean they're going to continue using
that back now so um if they come to me
for help I would say here's what I'm
willing to do I'm willing to lay out a
detailed game plan and I'm willing to
cheer you on as you go do it and if you
go do everything on there I may surprise
you with some other help but in the
meantime the help I'm going to give you
is information to reprogram how you're
doing life because your life sucks
you're not having fun that's only if
they ask because people I don't answer
questions that people don't ask anymore
I sit here all day and answer questions
on the radio but you asked so I'll
answer it but my friends and family that
come into my life doing stupid stuff I
just look at them and go get a cup of
coffee
and nothing I can do but if you ask
don't ask don't ask because I'll tell
you because I love you so much I'll
guide you out of this and I'll show you
the the hard answers to the questions
work hard you're gonna have a callus
you're gonna be tired
OT overt time is going to be a big part
of your life and you're going to pile up
so much cash that you keep the wolf away
from your door and we're going to jack
the 24 year old up and get her a life
that's sustainable living with Mom and
Daddy where their two kids is not a plan